it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the stories
behind the headlines for that we turn to
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond while we learn more about
Biden's business dealings Joe is
offering his own True Confessions
you know Laura when public figures let
their guard down that's often when the
truth comes tumbling out Joe Biden sat
for a wellness podcast because who else
would you turn to for wellness advice
and he offered these Sage tips for
colluding with world leaders to deceive
the public listen I will say to the
leader sometimes well why don't you let
me criticize you for this or thank you
for that or more and most of the time
they'll go okay or why don't you why
don't you criticize me why don't you
criticize me for my not doing something
and then I'll respond and say okay and
then you can do what you want to do
so basically Laura Joe Biden conspires
with world leaders to create a dumb show
for the public so they can all go out
and do what the hell they want to do
that's called deception and it's really
a bad look when you're being charged
with making money off of foreign
entities I just I honestly don't think
he knows what he's saying at this point
and I love the dark effect on both of
those men there that was very creepy it
was it was appropriate wreck yeah
they're very intimate almost
confessional and then the president
offered this advice to those who
encounter the frail elderly
it's like you know you're walking across
an intersection they don't let me do
that anymore
you walk across the intersection and
there's a you know an elderly man or
woman knowing they're waiting to see if
they have enough time just grabbing
their hand and walking across it's a
little tiny thing but it the anxiety it
relieves
good to know the anxiety is is being
decreased all the time
right looks like
sorry Raven he's talking about himself
is this great all right it looks like
he's he looks like he's going out of his
way now to acknowledge um his seventh
granddaughter after years of ignoring
her
yeah I have uh seven grandkids you know
every day I either text them or call
them being there
is is important and it makes such a
difference I think
now Laura this new affection for his
granddaughter is clearly happening
because the polling is so bad among
Democrats and especially the black
community this is Cheryl Underwood's
podcast from yesterday listen to this
they now want to acknowledge the other
baby I'm gonna tell you from the black
side no matter whether Friend or Foe
soon as the baby show up we love the
baby white people have no chill when it
comes to a baby showing up that they
never acknowledged
you know why all this matters Laura The
Washington Post found a 10 drop in the
turnout among black voters in the
midterms compared to 2018 and in a new
Washington Post poll 25 percent of black
respondents said they would be
disappointed if Joe Biden were elected
this is a bad time for Democrats and
their black constituents no
um Raymond I think that there's a lot of
votes for the taking there on the
illegal immigration issue and on issues
like this
well and and I think part of the reason
you're seeing this volatility in the
black community is for another reason
Kamala Harris here she was this weekend
what we need to do to reform the
criminal justice system which is
something I've been working on my entire
career as you know and that is about
restructuring and thinking about how we
restructure how we think about what
causes people to enter the system
especially if you enter the system
thinking about restructuring it Laura
I'm sure that would really focus us to
think about the entering and
restructuring Raymond did she lock up
all those people when she
writing their whole story she was like
go get them throw them the lock throw
away the key that was her reputation
when she was in you've been in power so
I'm not I'm not following the redo
finally image
finally Lord you'll remember Greta
thunberg famously chiding the United
Nations for their sluggish response on
climate change
how dare you
well it turns out she says this all the
time here's Greta from over the weekend
somebody spilled a drink at lunch
apparently
so sorry
how dare you you have stolen my dreams
and my childhood with your empty words
you know Lord gets it gets hard to take
any of this seriously it brings us full
circle to what Biden said at the top I
guess you say I'm going to criticize you
for this I'll say that you say this and
then we'll do whatever we want that's
what seems to be the play here with
Greta too it's all performance art it's
all we're all being punked and the
children of the children of the climate
as we know like we're looking forward to
that new release Raymond she she's
laughing at herself but she's really
laughing at us uh thanks Ray hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else